[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants posent pas trop
d'accord mon gros nounours tu leur
montre le livre et moi je leur raconte
la suite des aventures du petit
cornichons mon le seul nom propre
bonjour les nouveaux champs bonsoir
bishop et vient ensuite la new york ne
bouge pas comme chaud voilà tu est posée
et maintenant tu nous montres la suite
de l'histoire de cornichons et du chant
chez mazda avoue patron vous pouvez
raconter vous montrons notre petite amie
corniche on s'est perdus vous vous en
souvenez des enfants
oui et il a pas retrouvé ses parents
nice au cheval dadar et il s'est endormi
tout seul au bord de la mer mon pauvre
petit ses chaussures à la main corniche
on est au bord de l'eau et il regarde un
gros bateau qui s'approche tout
doucement
oui petits cornichons tu ne veux pas
venir travailler sur mon bateau demande
le capitaine j'ai besoin d'un petit
mousse qu'est-ce que s'annonce elle
mousse un tout jeune par un cornichon
qui est triste d'être tout seul accepte
avec joie
il monte sur le gros bateau monter la
grosse voile
cris le capitaine us dit le gros loup de
mer de sacs os x en tirant sur les gros
cordages de la grosse voile il s'il en a
une fois de plus montés la petite voile
cris le capitaine 10 10 le petit mousse
cornichons de sa petite voix en tirant
de toutes ses forces sur les petits
cordages de la petite voile au les
voiles blanches claque dans le vent qui
les gonfle elle pousse le bateau qui
part très vite dans la mer et qui arrive
bientôt
tout près d'une petite île déserte
moui cornichons cris le capitaine
cornichons jette langres dans l'eau le
bateau s'arrête s'est amusé à des temps
un bateau il y en a de la veine
cornichons comment je retiens est à sa
place
le gros loup de mer et le capitaine vont
pêcher des poissons tandis que notre
petit mousse corniche on ramasse sur la
plage des coquillages merwe
mieux avec lesquels il fait un beau
collier pour sa maman
il est gentil commission nous aussi on
fait des colliers pour notre maman quand
on est à la mer nous allons les enfants
l'histoire est finie
vous a plu ah oui elle est très jolie
cette histoire merci des marchands de
sable voulons les plus où tout vous
[Musique]
la chute un jeune homme beau ne pas
donner à voir les neuf pas nui du coc la
venue des promelles corbières bonne nuit
petit peu prône l bonne nuit petit
nicolas bonne nuit tous les enfants
allaient sagement vous coucher et faites
de beaux rêves fait pour me voir up trop
alors en route mon cher nounours bon et
nuit à demain à thomas botte tout
e
[Musique]